there's a manhunt underway after a  little girl nine years old was shot dead  in her own home two adults are uh in  hospital as a result of that incidence  this little one just getting ready for  bed and a man has shot her dead at home  there is now a manhunt under ways what  we're being told  by the police who say that this man does  not it's not fit to be on the streets of  liverpool and as i said that  investigation is well underway we've got  fraser there for us and he will update  us in just a few moments time but one  can't even begin to imagine little one  just getting ready for bed a man  bursts into the house shoots her dead  two adults also  ill as a result